le lundi forcément le jour de la
chronique sport de michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir grégory les
week-ends qui se suivent mais ne se
ressemblent pas du vent la semaine
dernière un très beau temps ce week-end
on va commencer cette rubrique avec du
rugby le championnat de fédérale 2
directions plaisir les plaisirs wap
peuvent jubiler le prc a fait tomber ce
dimanche le deuxième du classement
drancy à domicile les joies décuplée par
le scénario du match je vais vous faire
un résumé rapide de cette rencontre en
première période plaisir n'arrive pas à
prendre la mesure de son adversaire se
fait corriger 17 à 3 avec deux essais
concédés et forcément les murs ont dû
trembler dans les vestiaires
effectivement on en prend 15 7 points
mais on sait surtout dû à nos erreurs on
les met dans avec nos erreurs et fasse
une belle équipe comme ça c'est sûr
qu'on est sanctionné tout de suite il a
manqué un peu de maîtrise sur cette
première mi temps pour espérer faire
mieux pas prendre un but et on a plus
largement et 11 romeo question dans les
vestiaires
larbi le capitaine les entraîneurs et ça
nous a amené un coup de un coup de jus
pour finir ce match en deuxième période
les joueurs pc ware reviennent sur la
pelouse métamorphosé y arrive à inscrire
trois essais en 40 minutes de jeu mais
drancy a la balle de match vous le voyez
à l'écran dans les toutes dernières
secondes pour l'emporter
vous avez vu oui malheureusement il
laisse échapper la balle et ils
n'arrivent pas à conclure plaisir
l'emportent sur le fil en voilà on
revoit l'action au ralenti minots voilà
le plaisir l'emportent sur le fil 24 à
23 2 dernières pénalités et notamment la
dernière bon on s'en sort très bien avec
le poteau le 15 qui récupère qui fait un
en-avant dans l'en-but on commence on
pouvait pas avoir meilleur scénario
effectivement en terme de réussite
après j'ai envie de vous dire par
rapport à tous les matches qu'on a eu
avant
c'est un peu justice qu'aujourd'hui ça
tombe pour nous avec cette victoire
plaisir pointe à la 9e place du
championnat de fédérale 2 avec 7 points
d'avancé sur le premier relégable paris
université club
avec cet exploit le staff plaisir roy
espère désormais pouvoir terminer la
saison en milieu de tableau du rugby
toujours pour continuer un autre club
saint quentinois nickel dans ce
championnat de division honneur cette
fois ci le sky rugby n'a pas pu résister
aux assauts de l'entente maisons
laffitte saint jean les poissy leader du
championnat les saint quentinois se sont
lourdement inclinés 41 6 ce dimanche
après midi
au classement le sky reste 7e du
championnat avec un bilan de 5 victoires
1 nul et huit défaites depuis le début
de la saison et du football pour
terminer le championnat de régionale 3
trap a réussi une très belle prestation
ce week-end les trappistes se sont
imposés sur le score fleuve de 3 buts à
0 face à franconville une équipe de bas
de classement avec sept victoires très
pro prend la place de leader à boulogne
billancourt après 13 journées disputées
prochain match pour les trappistes ce
dimanche 24 février sur le terrain doni
un autre mal classé
suivra la suit avec attention merci
michael on vous retrouve dans votre
émission de 7,8 sport pour un résumé de
l'actualité sportive du week end
l'actualité aussi sportives à venir